they've walked these steps for
generations
oldham athletic football club dates back
to 1895
but the civil war here now between the
fans and the current ownership has hit
new depths
on saturday the fans stormed the pitch
as relegation from the football league
loomed they forced the match to stop and
then restart behind closed doors
and people at the club then used
advertising hoardings to ensure
supporters couldn't watch
you end up watching your team get
relegated from
from the bar at the back of the ground
and they've boarded the doors up because
they're playing it behind closed doors
you know it was just
it's just a terrible end to to what's
been a terrible four years and there's
too many individuals who get rich off
football and it should be the
communities that are at the heart of
football that benefit from that wealth
not agents not individual players
players are worth more in monetary value
than football clubs and that is wrong
fundamentally wrong
after the biggest clubs tried and failed
to go for a european super league last
year the demands for an independent
regulator grew louder
the prime minister was at another
greater manchester club to confirm that
it will now happen in england ferry fc
folded in 2019 the club has just been
resurrected by the fans if you look at
the the the emotion uh the commitment
that fans have to uh to to clubs up and
down the country it's it's the right
thing to do to to help them and to give
these clubs a future the tests for
owners will be tougher but as yet there
is no timetable for when these changes
will come into law preventing the kind
of crisis that they have here at oldham
athletic is at the heart of these
proposals most fans do back the ideas
being put forward
but crucially the government is talking
about financial oversight of football
clubs and not intervening directly to
redistribute the vast amounts of wealth
at the top of the game
there is resistance the idea of a levy
on big transfers providing extra revenue
for smaller clubs is not going to happen
the whole financial structure is such a
mess it's upside down it's it's totally
unfair
um so you know we need these things to
be implemented the owners of soon to be
non-league oldham athletic said their
relegation represents a total failure
for the fans change cannot come soon
enough
tom parmenter sky news oldham